welcome to episode 5 of the podcast
today we have Rodman Machado along the
executive chef at common ground here
we're going to talk about superfoods
we're going to talk about nourishing
your body we're going to talk about
congenital disease like diabetes and how
to prevent it we're going to talk about
generally just
right peludas medicine and the mission
here at common ground what common ground
is working towards which Robbins huge
burner so a lot of talk about food and
nourishing your body anything I think
that's it yeah check this out a shout
out thanks brother support with podcast
has been gone for a we're having a good
time so we hope you enjoy yourself Aloha
thank you hello